hi JP I'm wondering how the computer
program that rates university courses as
worthwhile or not is coming along well
it isn't rating them as worthwhile it's
rating them as postmodern neo-marxist or
not and it's actually fully developed I
was going to launch it and I didn't I
didn't design it uh somebody volunteered
to design it and presented it to me and
it seems to work very well I was going
to launch it at the end of August so
that this year's university students
could benefit from it but there was the
Charlottesville event and then I got
busy and I also wasn't feeling great and
so I just didn't hit the window of time
properly but I hope to be able to launch
it for the January incoming class to do
a video about what's wrong with the
university system the many things that
are wrong with the university system and
to launch the website at the same time I
also had people suggest to me that maybe
it wasn't a good idea that it would
increase polarization but I've thought
about that for about a month and a half
and I think that the benefit to the
consumer so that would be the informed
student outweighs any danger of
polarization
besides that something has to be done
because the situation in the
universities is really ridiculous so all
right so let's see what else we've got
here in the chat room DVS sk8er three
that's quite a mouthful says I'm
studying to be a teacher but I'm also an
introvert could this be a big problem
can I still be a successful teacher
actually what seems to predict success
of teaching best is intelligence and
conscientiousness that's the data so far
so if you're conscientious then you'll
probably be fine I mean extra introverts
have a harder time speaking in front of
groups but you can learn to do that you
know an introvert can become a very
successful public speaker may not enjoy
it the same way that an extrovert might
but that doesn't mean that you can't
learn those skills and what I would
recommend for an introvert is the same
thing that I do when I'm lecturing is I
never talked to the whole group
you know doesn't matter how big the
crowd is I'm always picking out
individuals in the group and it's
talking specifically to them so I'll
make a point to an individual and I
watch their face and see if they're
nodding and understanding right because
that way you make contact with the
entire audience and then you know I'll
talk to someone for about 15 seconds or
so I don't want to put them on the spot
too much and then I shift my attention
to someone else and I sort of pinpoint
around the room that keeps everybody in
the room focused on what I'm saying
because each person reflects the entire
crowd back to you and so I would say if
you're an introvert or if you want to
speak in public in general forget about
the damn crowd it doesn't exist
speak to people one at one at a time and
an introvert can do that just fine
so you know that's where your strengths
would be and I would say you're much
more likely to be unsuccessful as a
teacher if you don't work hard at it and
if you're not interested in and so if
you're an introvert I wouldn't worry
about that I don't think that that'll be
the biggest problem that you'll face so